winning the confidence vote in the
Senate was a crucial victory for prime
minister enrico letta against all
expectations Silvio Berlusconi pledged
his support and said his People of
Freedom Party would vote in favor of the
ruling coalition yamo it was a
last-minute about turn over the past
days the former prime minister had been
trying to topple letta's government
future at first LOL let her responded by
calling this vote he told the senate the
country needed stability and losing
would represent a fatal risk yep LOL
Parliament toe-to-toe I appeal to all of
Parliament for a vote of confidence to
realize our objectives give us a vote of
confidence for everything that has been
done in these few months a vote of
confidence that is not against anyone
but a vote of confidence for Italy I
wanna fiducia fairly Thalia Letta needed
votes from the center right cam to
secure a majority media reports
suggested he would get those even before
Berlusconi back down many PDL senators
were expected to go against Berlusconi's
wishes and support the government in the
confidence vote the climb down is being
seen as a major setback for Berlusconi
who is facing likely expulsion from the
Senate due to a tax fraud conviction
that would mean he'd lose political
immunity opening the way for further
legal proceedings on the streets of Rome
many expressed relief at the outcome
unhappy because Berlusconi and people
like him were put in their place de
seguro in kazan government collapse
would have been the worst possible
result so this is much better we
disagree oh man yo cozy the vote of
confidence in the government means Italy
can continue on its course of economic
reform